foreign
[Music]
how long can they keep us in Asteroid
City legally I mean
well I'm not an attorney but I'd say as
long as they like I think we'd have to
file an injunction and successfully
argue the case six months to a year of
course we'd also need to initiate a
civil suit for a loss of income maybe we
should just walk out right now I'm not
sure they could stop us without killing
somebody interesting idea
what kind of mileage do you think that
jet pack gets ask Roger or his son
apparently he's being prosecuted for
revealing State secrets I'll never make
it stick I'm in no hurry I like the
desert I like aliens oh
how'd you get that back the projects
remain under secure lockdown no
stargazers permitted personal access
without the expression my son invented
this death rate it may be true
anymore okay everyone please it's been a
typical quarantine
Stand Down you hear that General Gibson
says Stand Down you married of course
[Applause]
this isn't the beginning
isn't it
is it
probably not and that's maybe it is
I don't like the way that guy looked at
us okay the alien oh how did he look
like we're doomed
maybe we are
hmm
he took a picture of me
uh-huh
why
I'm a photographer
you didn't ask permission I never asked
permission
why not
because I work in trenches battlefields
and combat zones
really
uh-huh
you mean you're a war photographer
mostly
Sometimes I cover sporting events my
name is Augie Steinbeck
when are you gonna do that
picture
well
if it's any good I guess I'll try to
sell it to a magazine now that you're
mention it Mitch Campbell eating a
waffle
I strongly question whether your
daughter's Silly Putty resembles
anything from outer space it's not silly
it's called s'mores tozium this is
excellent thank you it's really all the
machines doing what the devil do you
know about Astro geology anyway JJ
whatever that stands for I just
maintained the workings Kelly's thesis
is supported by some of the outdated
evidence not in my opinion I like the
Silly Putty or smartodium in fact I just
quoted what he said his son's project
might very well have killed us all today
by the way coming from the family that
brought us the electromagnetic death
weapon of course it's lethal so you
admit it not to mentioned brainiac's
flag I mean he's trying to provoke World
War III or something the jet propulsion
belt is imminently safe I allow an
eight-year-old boy to operate it in fact
I did Ricky's cousin chip and he broke
the solo flight altitude record
they're strange aren't they they're
children compared to normal people yes
that's correct it's true
hello
we met before I'm the mother of that
cookie Trooper who idolizes you I know I
thought you might not recognize me out
of uniform
you're very good in the one about the
in the brothel who gets amnesia
because he's a pediatrician you are very
obviously maybe my favorite character
ever I don't know why nobody else liked
it oh yes me neither thank you some
people liked it oh I'm sure I did I hope
you're aware you and your accomplices
may still face felony prosecution
possibly even a treason charge I'll
fight it all the way to the Supreme
Court if necessary and when it's just in
from the president
he's Furious thanks a lot Ricky I don't
know what to say General Gibson don't
apologize dad the public has a right to
the truth this tribunal is a mockery
what about steenbeck who took the
photograph it's on the front page of
every newspaper on the planet can't we
arrest him as well unfortunately no he
dropped a print in the mail to his photo
agency first thing Tuesday morning and
the postman got it before we did he's
innocent supposedly he did a nude of
Mitch Campbell too
you're not here we're not there the car
exploded
come get the girls I have to stay here
with Woodrow another chauffeur I'm the
grandfather where are you asteroid City
Farm Road 6 Mile 75.
Junior stargazers and Space Cadets each
year we celebrate asteroid day
commemorating September 23 3007 BC when
the Arid Plains meteorite made Earth
impact
I don't know why nobody else liked it oh
what are those pulses indicate what oh
the beeps and blips we don't know some
of our information about outer space May
no longer be completely accurate anyway
there's still only nine planets in the
solar system as far as we know Billy
except now there's an alien
foreign
like we're doomed
maybe we are I've just informed the
president how long can they keep us an
asteroid City legally the world will
never be the same that's an alien doing
jumping jacks that's an alien a top hat
what's out there the meaning of life
maybe there is one are you married I'm a
widower but don't tell my kids you're
saying her mother died three weeks ago
let's say she's in heaven which doesn't
exist for me of course but you're
Episcopalian in my loneliness I learned
to give complete and unquestioning Faith
to the people I love I don't know if
that includes you but it included my
daughter and your four children
sometimes I think I feel more at home
outside the Earth's atmosphere oh wow
me too they're strange aren't they
they're children
compared to normal people yes that's
correct it's true
going so fast
[Music]
I don't know the scene you want to see
it
did I say yes you didn't say anything I
meant yes my mouth didn't speak
here we go and
[Music]
asteroid City we wanted a slightly
exaggerated desert desert to set a play
I had a thought that we might find a
place that was very very flat and open
and build our rocks and build our town
the place where we filmed chinchon about
an hour from Madrid well if you want
flat land and you decide you want to
shoot in Europe I think you'll soon find
yourself in Spain quite a perfect spot
for us to do this and with the right
amount of room another 10 Paces forward
Sandy
you see that wonderful crackly patch
right out there between the dead
cactuses and the dried up riverbed I
think so that's your parcel we laid it
out and we made miniature rocks and
we've figured it out for the location we
had originally looked at locations
ultimately the more time we spent
looking at images of different places
the more I started to feel like I wanted
a bit of each rather than building it in
a real landscape to instead create a bit
of the landscape it's part of the play
line up single file lunchtime lunchtime
lineup single file
my word it's hot asteroid City the town
itself slowly in the course of time Adam
stockhausen and I working together on
this I guess the thing was to try to
make buildings that were as evocative of
the time as we possibly could and it's
interesting they could be in the place
always needed to have a certain mystery
you know there's a freeway on-ramp there
that goes to Nowhere there's a crater on
the edge of the town and an observatory
and the various things we needed for our
story we built it all and the great
thing was that it was a place where we
could work with a very small group which
way did he go
hmm well once it was built we could be a
tiny group in this what seemed like an
abandoned town we could golf cart
ourselves to the set every day and back
home and work just the way I like to
work which is the actors come to the set
ready to shoot already in costume and
there's no trailers and there's no
trucks anywhere that you can see them
and we can be a bit like a student film
though we were a student film on an
enormous giant set in the middle of
Spain
okay everybody ready
[Music]
about six foot seven
tall brother
cat legs
[Music]
[Applause]
good okay great cut
[Music]
thank you